hi this is presh tallaker this season of
the simpsons featured a crossover
episode with futurama that had some
pretty cool math equations
here's a screen capture i'm going to
identify each of the equations and then
describe more about each one in the rest
of the video this equation on the upper
left hand side is known as ferma's
little theorem which is an interesting
result in number theory
on the bottom is another result from
number theory known as the prime number
theorem which describes the density of
primes
this tsp is in p refers to the traveling
salesman problem which is actually an
unsolved problem but there's a claim
here that it's known in polynomial time
the remaining equations are also from an
unsolved problem known as the riemann
hypothesis
so firma's little theorem says that if
you take a number a and raise it to the
power of p minus 1 you'll always have a
remainder of one
relative to p
here we want p to be prime and a to be
relatively prime to p
so we can do an example let's take the
prime five as p
if we take any number that's relatively
prime to five
we'll find that raising that number to
the fourth power will always leave a
remainder of one when divided by five so
it's one more than a multiple of five
next up is the prime number theorem this
is set this theorem says that the number
of primes less than x is asymptotically
x divided by the natural log of x
so for example if x is a hundred there
actually are 25 primes less than it and
the approximation gets pretty close
the traveling salesman problem
asks given a list of cities and
distances between the cities what's the
shortest route that travels each of the
cities exactly once
now you could brute force this problem
but becomes very difficult as the number
of cities increases
computer scientists believe this is an
np hard problem which means it cannot be
solved in polynomial time
the final problem is the riemann
hypothesis
this is actually even a very difficult
problem to describe
the hypothesis is that a particular
function
when you want to look for solutions it
only happens when the real part of the
argument is equal to one-half
this problem has been unsolved since
1859 but if you can solve it there's a
million dollar prize to it
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon to get exclusive rewards
you can catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions on twitter at
preshtalwacker and you can get my books
listed on my website